Hey guys. Hey guys. Well, everybody knows who mine is. What is? Favorite candy. Didn't you just say favorite candies? No. Oh no.
大家好。大家好。好吧，大家都知道我的。是什么？最喜欢的糖果。你刚刚不是说最喜欢的糖果吗？不是。哦，不。
You were just thinking that? Oh my God, Sean. He's hearing candy voices again. Are you thinking all the time favorite candies? I thought you just said name your favorite candy. No, nobody said favorite candies. Oh boy, welcome to Smartless. Smart.
你刚才在想那个？天哪，肖恩。他又听到糖果的声音了。你脑子里一直在想最喜欢的糖果吗？我还以为你刚刚说的是说出你最喜欢的糖果。没有，没人说最喜欢的糖果。天哪，欢迎来到 SmartLess。
Lias. Smart. Lias. Smart. Lias. Smart. Lias. Smart.
SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。
Lias. Smart. Lias. Smart. Lias. So, listener, Sean is in England. London, England. And what's Sean, what you're doing there,
SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。所以，听众朋友们，肖恩在英国。英国伦敦。肖恩，你在那儿做什么，
this is the Edgar Wright. This is just a little cameo in the Running Man movie directed by Edgar Wright. You went to England to record some cameos? Uh-huh. Okay. Yeah, how much you got, how much you got? Okay, hey, it's Sean Hayes, happy birthday. Gary, how much you got how much you got? Okay. Hey, it's Sean Hayes. Happy birthday Gary
这是埃德加·赖特。这只是在埃德加·赖特导演的电影《逃跑人》里的一个小客串。你去了英国去拍一些客串戏？嗯。好吧。是的，你拿了多少，你拿了多少？好吧，嘿，我是肖恩·海斯，祝你生日快乐。加里，你拿了多少，你拿了多少？好吧。嘿，我是肖恩·海斯。祝加里生日快乐
Congratulations Sean you've got a slide of London. Yeah, Sean you've negotiated a very nice accommodations for yourself there. Yes It's wonderful. Thanks good for you pictures. Yeah. Oh Lovely, so that's a at least a one-bedroom suite. You've got there for your cameo Oh, lovely, so that's at least a one bedroom suite you've got there for your cameo? Well, we get two bedrooms because there's snoring happening with Scotty. Oh, so you've come out of pocket is what you're saying.
恭喜肖恩，你拿到了伦敦的一笔钱。是的，肖恩，你在那边为自己谈妥了非常好的住宿条件。是的。太棒了。谢谢。真为你高兴。照片。 yeah. 哦，太好了，所以你那个客串至少是个一室一厅的套房吧？哦，太好了，所以你那个客串至少是个一室一厅的套房吧？好吧，我们有两个卧室，因为斯科蒂会打呼噜。哦，所以你的意思是这是你自掏腰包。
You're gonna spend everything you're making just to keep Scotty out of your bed. You know, also, I know we talked about this before, but the jet lag thing, it is unbelievable. What time is it right now for you? It's 5.30 and like 20 minutes ago, my head was bobbing and like. Well yeah, cause it's 9.30 in the morning
你打算花光你赚的钱，只为了不让斯科蒂上你的床。你知道，还有，我知道我们以前讨论过这个，但是时差的问题，真是不可思议。你现在几点？现在是5点30分，大约20分钟前，我的头还在点来点去，像。好吧，是的，因为现在是早上9点30分
here in Los Angeles. So you just have spent all night awake. Night up, right. Let's just say this, it's safe to say, and I mean this with a tremendous amount of love. Uh oh. Uh oh. You operate, your normal life is if you have jet lag.
这里是洛杉矶。所以你刚刚一整夜没睡。一整夜没睡，对吧。我们这么说吧，可以这么说，我是带着无比的爱意说这番话的。噢，不。噢，不。你的运作方式，你的正常生活就像你有严重的ジェットラグ（时差）一样。
It's totally terrible. It's terrible. You should be sent away to a sleep, I mean it. Because. No, I did it, I did a sleep study and all that. I have apnea and all that. Something needs to happen because you're a candidate for dropping dead.
这简直太糟糕了。太糟糕了。你应该被送去睡眠中心，我是认真的。因为。不，我做过，我做过睡眠研究之类的。我有呼吸暂停综合症之类的。有些事情必须发生，因为你是猝死的候选人。
What do you mean? Wait, are you saying because he's tired all the time? Well, he just has no, his. Well, I just sleep three or four hours and I'm up, then I sleep another three or four hours and I'm up. His sleep hygiene is, yeah, it's really bad. And I mean this, I know that I'm sort of joking around, but it is true that it's a, you know, it's serious.
你什么意思？等等，你是说因为他总是很累吗？好吧，他就是没有，他的。好吧，我只是睡三四个小时就醒了，然后我再睡三四个小时就醒了。他的睡眠卫生习惯，是的，真的很糟糕。我是认真的，我知道我在开玩笑，但这确实是一个，你知道的，严重的问题。
No, I know, I know. But I tried, listen, I did the thing, I went to the, you know, got the sleep study, you know, and then they say, you have apnea, it's really bad, and they say, they sell you that machine, so I bought the machine, and I just, I tried it for a month, I just, there's so, I could talk for an hour about all the issues I have.
不，我知道，我知道。但我试过了，听着，我做了那件事，我去了，你知道的，做了睡眠研究，你知道的，然后他们说，你有呼吸暂停综合症，非常严重，他们说，他们向你推销那台机器，所以我买了那台机器，我试了一个月，我只是，有太多，我可以讲一个小时关于我所有的毛病。
One thing I didn't tell you, Jason, I think I told. Wait, so are you still using the hoses? No, I'm done, I can't do it. Right, so now you're just risking, you're risking suffocating to death every night. Yeah, your health. Yeah, I sleep better without the machine. No, you don't.
有一件事我没告诉你，杰森，我想我告诉过。等等，所以你还在用那些面罩管道吗？不，我不用了，我受不了。好吧，所以你现在是在冒险，你每晚都在冒着窒息身亡的风险。对，你的健康。对，没有那台机器我睡得更好。不，你没有。
I do, I'm telling you. All right. I can't, I can't, but there is something funny that happens with that machine. You know, you know what it is, right? You hook it up to your nose, your nostrils, it goes through your nostrils and it covers your mouth and blah, blah, blah.
我真的有，我跟你说。好吧。我受不了，我受不了，但那台机器确实发生了一些好笑的事情。你知道，你知道那是什么，对吧？你把它连接到你的鼻子，你的鼻孔，它穿过你的鼻孔，然后遮住你的嘴，等等等等。
And so I'm all set up and Scott, and Scottie comes in, this is like a few weeks ago, to say goodnight to me and I have it on so you can't really talk because all the air is blowing inside of your mouth. So he goes. Yeah, you're like in the ER. Yeah, just like in the ER. And he goes, all right, babe, I love you, goodnight.
然后我一切就绪，斯科特，然后斯科特进来了，大概是几周前，来对我说晚安，我戴着它，所以你真的无法说话，因为所有的空气都在你的嘴里吹。所以他说。是啊，你就像在急诊室里一样。对，就像在急诊室里一样。他说，好了，宝贝，我爱你，晚安。
And I go, I love you too. You can't take it out of your mouth. Is it? I love you too. But you're now Scotty's real, I mean, you're already his dream guy, but now you're his real, because now you've got a whole sci-fi look to you. You're scratching every inch of his.
然后我说，我也爱你。你没法把它从嘴里拿出来。是吗？我也爱你。但你现在是斯科蒂真正的，我是说，你已经是他的梦中情人了，但现在你是他真正的，因为你现在有一种科幻小说的造型。你在抓挠他的每一寸。
I look like Prometheus, the guy in Prometheus. Oh, God. So now does that get him excited? Are you guys, are you having an increased physical life or an increased one? No, God, just the opposite. Yeah. We're into sort of just like a seasonal touch up. Yeah, what do you mean?
我看起来像普罗米修斯，《普罗米修斯》里的那个家伙。哦，天哪。那这会让他兴奋吗？你们，你们的身体生活增加了还是增加了？不，天哪，恰恰相反。是的。我们有点像季节性修补。是的，什么意思？
It's like once in the spring, once in the winter, once in the fall. You want to know the rates of their sex life? I do, I do, mean? It's like once in the spring, once in the winter, once in the fall. You want to know the rates of their sex life? I do, I do, let's do that. I'm sure our guest will wait. Let's do that. I like hearing, we get updates from Amanda when you guys do it.
就像春天一次，冬天一次，秋天一次。你想知道他们性生活的频率吗？我想，我想，什么意思？就像春天一次，冬天一次，秋天一次。你想知道他们性生活的频率吗？我想，我想，我们来聊聊这个。我确信我们的嘉宾会等的。我们来聊聊这个。我喜欢听，当你们做爱时，我们会从阿曼达那里得到更新。
Yeah, right? Oh yeah, unsolicited. And then Jason, I'm like, hey Amanda, honestly, you got to know that I don't want to know this. Yeah, don't want to know about anybody, unsolicited. And then Jason, I'm like hey, Amanda, honestly, you gotta know that I don't wanna know this. Yeah, don't wanna know about anybody, by the way. Yeah. Oh, she loves to share. I know.
是啊，对吧？哦，是的，不请自来的。然后杰森，我就像，嘿，阿曼达，老实说，你得知道我不想知道这个。是的，不想知道任何人的，不请自来的。然后杰森，我就像嘿，阿曼达，老实说，你得知道我不想知道这个。是的，顺便说一句，不想知道任何人的。是的。哦，她喜欢分享。我知道。
It's sweet. God bless her. It is sweet. Will, thanks for combing your hair. It started a little bit rough. It's just sweaty, I just worked out. You don't need to scream, okay? We're all exercising, all right? Okay. Fuck. You don't need to scream, okay, we're all exercising. All right?
真贴心。上帝保佑她。确实很贴心。威尔，谢谢你梳头。一开始有点艰难。只是出汗了，我刚锻炼完。你不需要尖叫，好吗？我们都在锻炼，好吗？好吧。操。你不需要尖叫，好吗，我们都在锻炼。好吗？
Fuck. What are you doing for workouts over there in New York? Are you outside or are you inside? No, no, no, I'm inside. I'm mixing it up. I've got a few different things that I'm doing and Downey put me in touch with these guys who've opened a new facility
操。你在纽约那边都做什么锻炼？你在室外还是室内？不，不，不，我在室内。我在做各种组合。我有几种不同的事情在做，唐尼让我联系了这些家伙，他们刚开了一个新设施
that I'm going to go look at next week that apparently they do all sorts of cool stuff. Oh really? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And I'm in touch with a guy and I just haven't had it. What kind of new stuff? Like stuff we don't know about? Yeah, just like new stuff.
我下周要去看看，显然他们做了各种很酷的事情。哦，真的吗？对，对，对，对。我跟一个人联系上了，只是还没去。什么样的新设施？比如我们不知道的东西？对，就像一些新鲜玩意儿。
Like how to kill a guy with a ballpoint pen. Well that, yeah, it's just more like street fighting. You know. But you get hot looking while you're doing it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. All right, are you guys ready? Yeah. I mean I guess so.
比如如何用圆珠笔杀一个人。好吧，那个，是的，这更像是街头格斗。你知道的。但你在做的时候看起来很性感。对，对，对。好了，你们准备好了吗？是的。我想是的。
Do you have a whole intro? Well, our next guest grew up in England, okay? Oh, okay. But you know what, she's a real whippersnapper. She's, this 20-year-old has already done a lot. What? Yeah. What?
你有一段完整的开场白吗？好吧，我们的下一位嘉宾在英国长大，好吗？哦，好吧。但你知道吗，她是个真正的机灵鬼。她，这个20岁的女孩已经做了很多事情。什么？对。什么？
She's received multiple nominations for Emmys and SAG. She's produced and starred in her own franchise. She's written a New York Times bestseller, now being adapted for the screen by an Oscar nominee. She's got her own global beauty product line. She's a star of one of the most successful shows in the world and still at just 20 years old, she's the proud mother of 10 children.
她获得了艾美奖和演员工会奖的多项提名。她制作并主演了自己的系列电影。她写了一本《纽约时报》畅销书，现在正被一位奥斯卡提名人改编成电影。她拥有自己的全球美妆产品线。她是世界上最成功的节目之一的明星，而且在年仅20岁的时候，她已经是10个孩子的骄傲母亲。
What are you talking about? They all have four legs. It's all one of his weird intros. Go ahead. Who is it? Yeah, they've all got four legs, but she doesn't love them any less. Oh my God. Guys, please welcome Miss Millie Bobby Brown.
你在说什么？它们都有四条腿。这又是他那些奇怪的开场白之一。继续。是谁？是的，它们都有四条腿，但这并不影响她对它们的爱。天哪。伙计们，请欢迎米莉·波比·布朗。
No way! You guys. No way! Oh my God. You guys, it's very hard to stay quiet while you're taking the piss out of each other. It's really hard. Now, Millie... Millie, it's not Millie Bobbs signing, right?
不会吧！你们。不会吧！天哪。伙计们，当你们互相开玩笑时，要保持安静太难了。真的很难。现在，米莉……米莉，不是米莉·波比·签名，对吧？
It's Millie. Yeah, Millie. And we're not doing... Are we doing the Bon Giovi as well? You did take his name. Yes, I am, like legally. But like stage names saying the same. So how are you introducing yourself?
是米莉。对，米莉。我们没在做……我们连邦·乔维（Bon Jovi）也一起拿来用了吗？你确实用了他的姓。是的，我用了，就像合法的那样。但艺名还是保持不变。那你现在怎么介绍自己？
Hi, my name is. When we sue you. Yeah, we want to get it right. It'll be Millie Bobby Bon Jovi if you sue me. Okay, what do you mean if? Now Will, you're fairly close to her father-in-law, is that correct? I want to say fairly close,
嗨，我叫……当我们起诉你的时候。是的，我们想弄对。如果你起诉我的话，那就是米莉·波比·邦·乔维了。好吧，你什么意思叫如果？现在，威尔，你和她的公公相当亲近，对吗？我想说相当亲近，
I've known him for a number of years. Yeah, he's a great dude. The best. A great dude, a past guest of the show here. Past guest of the show, great guy. Yeah, yeah, we've had John on here. He's a great musician, talented guy, great guy. What kind of father-in-law is he? Fantastic.
我认识他很多年了。是的，他是个极好的家伙。最棒的。一个极好的家伙，也是本节目的老嘉宾。本节目的老嘉宾，极好的家伙。对，对，我们让约翰上过节目。他是个伟大的音乐家，有才华的家伙，极好的家伙。他是一个什么样的公公？棒极了。
Busy? Yeah, like it's been so great because I grew up, obviously, in the public eye and he started, you know, so young, like, so it was, it's really nice because he, you know, obviously us being, he's a man and I'm a woman, so we deal with our separate things, but to be able to come together sometimes and when I need him,
很忙吗？是的，这真是太棒了，因为我显然是在公众的目光下长大的，而他开始得，你知道的，很年轻，所以，这真的很棒，因为他，你知道的，显然我们在一起，他是个男人，我是个女人，所以我们要处理各自不同的事情，但有时能够聚在一起，当I need him,
he is very much there for me in like the best ways, like always like making sure I need him, he is very much there for me in the best ways, always making sure I'm okay, if there's anything that's ever going on, I'm always like, can you help me out in this situation? And he's just so informative. Talking about the weirdness of the business, yeah. I mean, just, yeah, it's like, his wisdom is ridiculous. Not a lot he hasn't been through. Yeah, and just like, but also such a great person,
he is very much there for me in like the best ways, like always like making sure I need him, he is very much there for me in the best ways, always making sure I'm okay, if there's anything that's ever going on, I'm always like, can you help me out in this situation? And he's just so informative. 谈到这个行业的怪异之处，是的。我是说，仅仅是，是的，他的智慧简直荒谬。没有什么经历是他没经历过的。是的，而且就像，也是一个非常好的人，
so for me it's like, yeah, we talk about the whole fame thing, but it doesn't really come up in conversation. It's more about like the kind of person he and his, like his wife, my mother-in-law is. Like they are just, they're just really good people. And like they just do good and they're good people. And so I just strive to be like them. Yeah, I like that. They're like, they're like, really, really admirably normal people. Well, yeah, like, which is, you know, yeah. But also they did everything together, like,
所以对我来说就像，是的，我们谈论整个名气的事情，但它并没有真正在谈话中出现。更多的是关于他以及他的妻子，我的婆婆是怎样的人。就像他们真的，他们真的是很好的人。就像他们只做好事，他们是好人。所以我只是努力成为像他们那样的人。是的，我喜欢这样。他们就像是，非常非常令人钦佩的正常人。好吧，是的，就像，你知道的，是的。但他们也一起做所有事情，就像，
which is so beautiful, like everything, they, they, they start their high school sweethearts, so to be able to go through that all together as a team, they make such a wonderful team, such great parents, obviously, they're four kids. Yeah, Dorothea, right? That's his wife, she's amazing, she's really cool.
这太美妙了，就像所有事，他们，他们，他们是高中时的甜心，所以能够作为一个团队一起经历这一切，他们组成了一个如此美妙的团队，如此棒的父母，显然，他们有四个孩子。是的，多萝西娅，对吧？那是他的妻子，她太棒了，她真的很酷。
She really is, so I've been really lucky. Like, never, you know, I have, my parents are English. Your dad's amazing, please tell him hello. Love that guy. You know he loves you so much. Wait, how do you know her dad, Jason? You guys, easy, don't worry about it, okay? Wait, wait, wait, Millie. How do you how does your dad know Jason? Going to the I'm asking her not you we were at an award show party my dad like of course
她真的是，所以我真的很幸运。就像，从来没有，你知道的，我有，我的父母是英国人。你爸爸太棒了，请代我向他问好。很喜欢那个家伙。你知道他非常爱你。等等，你怎么认识她爸爸的，杰森？你们，轻松点，别担心，好吧？等等，等等，等等，米莉。你怎么，你爸爸怎么认识杰森的？去，我在问她，不是你，我们在一个颁奖典礼的派对上，我爸爸就像当然
That's where you'll find them. That's where you find my father apparently. No, it's oh Jason oh no, Jason. You were I you were... I've got a catering company. Never mind. No, I think there was... They just deliver nuts. I think you... I want to say you were nominated. Something like that.
那是你会找到他们的地方。那显然是你找到我父亲的地方。不，哦杰森，哦不，杰森。你当时，我当时……我开了一家餐饮公司。没关系。不，我想当时有……他们只是送坚果的。我想你……我想说你被提名了。诸如此类的事。
We were... That doesn't sound right. And I was too, I think. So we were together at this party and my dad never does this. He came up to me, he's like, do you think that you could go up to Jason Bateman for me? Because I love him. And I was like...
我们当时……听起来不太对。我想我也是。所以我们一起在这个派对上，我爸爸从来不这样。他走过来对我说，你觉得你能替我去找杰森·巴特曼吗？因为我很喜欢他。然后我当时……
I was like 14. I was like, sure. So I go up and walk over and I'm like, hi! Like, this is my dad. And anyway, my dad is like the sweetest person, but he is, and he's so personable, so funny, he's so English, like you would know. He would be, the banter is endless with him, and so he kind of just makes friends with really anyone.
我当时14岁。我说，当然可以。所以我走过去，走近然后说，嗨！就像，这是我爸爸。总之，我爸爸是个最甜美的人，但他确实，他很有人格魅力，非常有趣，他非常英国化，就像你会知道的那样。他会，跟他斗嘴是没完没了的，所以他基本上能和任何人交朋友。
Like he, yeah, I mean he's really great. Like he got a coconut cake from Tom Cruise this year. Like, do you know what I mean? Like, he's just that kind of guy. Like, makes friends with everyone, loves everyone, and you just happen to be one of his favorite people. And yeah, that's kind of like... Up until he met him.
就像他，是的，我的意思是真的很棒。比如今年他从汤姆·克鲁斯那里得到了一个椰子蛋糕。就像，你知道我的意思吗？他就是那种人。就像，和每个人交朋友，爱每个人，而你恰好成了他最喜欢的人之一。所以，这就有点像……直到他遇到他。
Up until, yeah. Of course, and then he said, wow, never meet your idols. Now, since you started so young, he must have been on set with you a bunch, and then once you passed 18, now you no longer get to share full days with him. Because I remember that transition in my life
直到，是的。当然，然后他说，哇，永远不要见你的偶像。现在，既然你这么早就出道了，他一定经常陪你在片场，然后一旦你过了18岁，你就不再能和他分享整整一天的时间了。因为我记得我生活中的那个转变
with my parents, it's like you miss them a bit, yeah? Yeah, well, it's really interesting because when I turned 18, it was just really weird, like, well, what do we do now? And do you still want to come? When I turned 18, it was this really weird, what do we do now? And do you still want to come? Because it's also like, you know. I can drive now, Dad.
和我的父母在一起，就像你会有点想念他们，对吧？是的，好吧，这真的很有趣，因为当我18岁的时候，这真的很奇怪，就像，好吧，我们现在该做什么？你还想来吗？当我18岁的时候，这是一个非常奇怪的，我们现在该做什么？你还想来吗？因为这也是像，你知道的。我现在可以开车了，爸爸。
Yeah, and also just like, I know it's boring. I know what you're doing is like, it's sat there boring. But he now is just my manager and we do everything together. We sign deals together, figure out my next everything together. helps me run my production company. We are developing new stories every day. He's a very creative man. He usually follows me everywhere. We have separation anxiety and he is the worst for it. He doesn't like to admit it, but he really is.
是的，而且还有就像，我知道这很无聊。我知道你在做的事就像，坐在那儿很无聊。但他现在只是我的经纪人，我们什么都一起做。我们一起签合同，一起想我接下来的所有事情。他帮我运营我的制作公司。我们每天都在开发新的故事。他是一个非常有创造力的人。他通常去哪里都跟着我。我们有分离焦虑症，而他是最严重的一个。他不喜欢承认这一点，但他真的是。
So anytime I'm not in England, they'll basically follow me around. This is the longest time, and he'll get out his calendar in his office and he'll be like, not with Millie, not with Millie. And he's like, okay, I'm not with you for three weeks. Like, what are we going to do? I'm going to be like that.
所以任何我不在英国的时候，他们基本都会跟着我到处跑。这是最长的一次，他会在办公室里拿出生日日历，然后说，不在米莉身边，不在米莉身边。然后他会说，好吧，我有三周不在你身边。就像，我们要做什么？我会像那样。
That's going to be hard for me when my girls leave. What do you mean? Well, when they go to college, you know, because I like my daughters. Don't look so confused. Sorry, no, I'm really, this is news to all of us. Sorry, Millie. Yeah, their names are...
等我的女儿们离开时，这对我会很难。什么意思？好吧，当她们上大学时，你知道的，因为我喜欢我的女儿们。别看起来这么困惑。抱歉，不，我真的很，这对我我们所有人来说都是新闻。抱歉，米莉。是的，她们的名字是……
There we go. Hey, Millie, how old were you? We know JB, I know JB is like, you've been worrying about them going to college since they were eight. I know, it's true. You're the first guy whose kids have gone away. Shut up, Bateman.
好了。嘿，米莉，你多大了？我们知道JB，我知道JB就像，你从她们八岁起就在担心她们上大学的事了。我知道，是真的。你是第一个孩子离家的家伙。闭嘴，巴特曼。
Hey, Millie, can I ask you a question? He has been, he's been like teary-eyed for 10 years. I know, it's very true. Millie, how old were you? What was your first foray into performing, like whose idea was it? Was it your mom and dad going like, all right, we've got a real hot ticket on our hands here, we need to put her into something?
嘿，米莉，我能问你个问题吗？他一直，他已经热泪盈眶10年了。我知道，这是真的。米莉，你多大了？你第一次涉足表演是什么时候，是谁的主意？是你的爸爸妈妈说，好吧，我们手里有一张热门票，我们需要让她去参加某种活动？
Or were you like, I gotta go do something? Like, what was that process? No, my parents are like, you know, my dad worked on a fruit and veg stand. Like he worked at a market, a fruit and vegetable market. So my dad did that the majority of his life. And that goes back, like actually we have pictures of our family in like the 1800s,
还是你自己说，我得去做点什么？像，那个过程是怎样的？不，我父母就像，你知道的，我爸爸在水果蔬菜摊上工作。就像他在一个市场上工作，一个水果蔬菜市场。所以我的爸爸大半辈子都在做那个。这可以追溯到，实际上我们有19世纪我们家族的照片，
like doing that same thing. No kidding? Yeah, so it's like florist. What part of the UK was that in? In Dorset, so in the countryside of England. Okay, nice. And so that's what my dad did. My mom, she had four kids.
就像做同样的事情。真的吗？是的，所以就像花商。那是英国的什么地方？在多塞特，也就是英国的乡村。好的，不错。这就是我爸爸做的。我妈妈，她有四个孩子。
She had her last daughter when she was 41. So she's been the best, most present mom ever and been very lucky to have that time with her. Where are you in that order? I'm third. Third, okay. So my older sister's 30. My older brother is 27. And then my younger sister's 30, my older brother is 27,
她在41岁时生了最后一个女儿。所以她一直是个最好、最陪伴左右的妈妈，能有那段和她在一起的时光真的很幸运。你在那个顺序里排第几？我是老三。老三，好吧。所以我的大姐30岁。我的大哥哥27岁。然后我的妹妹30岁，我的大哥哥27岁，
and then my younger sister is 13. Wow, amazing. Yeah, they had gaps, it was really weird. And yeah, so basically I... JB, you have a gap, right? Like 88 to 92, is that a big gap for you? Oh, I thought you had this one between my teeth, I can whistle with it.
然后我的小妹妹13岁。哇，太惊人了。是的，他们有代沟，真的很奇怪。是的，基本上我……JB，你有代沟，对吧？就像88年到92年，对你来说是个很大的代沟吗？哦，我以为你有这个，我牙齿中间的这个，我可以用它吹口哨。
I remember you saying 88 to 92 is a big gap for you? Oh, I thought you had this one. This one between my teeth. I can whistle with it. No, 88 to, I remember you said, 88 to 92 is a big gap for you. Yeah. So there you are. You're in the UK. Your dad's working selling fruit and veg. Amazing. Yeah. And I've always been,
我记得你说过88年到92年对你来说是个很大的代沟？哦，我以为你有这个。我牙齿中间的这个。我可以用它吹口哨。不，88年到，我记得你说过，88年到92年对你来说是个很大的代沟。是的。所以你就在那儿。你在英国。你爸爸在卖水果和蔬菜。太棒了。是的，我一直都，
I always loved dancing and singing. Like, it was not, like, acting, I didn't really even know it was a job. Like, I didn't know it existed. And then we moved to Orlando, Florida from England, kind of randomly. Really? Not for you, not for performance?
我一直很喜欢跳舞和唱歌。就像，不是，像演戏，我甚至不知道那是一份工作。就像，我不知道它的存在。然后我们从英国搬到了佛罗里达州奥兰多，有点像随机的。真的吗？不是为了你，不是为了表演？
No, just because my family, I would like to say, and even now we're still very like, we're nomads. Like we kind of just, if we never take a plane, we always drive. We're always just like that kind of family. If we want to go somewhere, we'll just get in the car and go. We've always been like that, never kind of, we don't need a lot to plan.
不，只是因为我的家，我想说，甚至现在我们还是很像，我们是游牧民。就像我们某种程度上只是，如果我们从不坐飞机，我们总是开车。我们一直都是那种家庭。如果我们想去某个地方，我们就会上车出发。我们一直都是那样，从来不怎么，我们不需要做太多计划。
Her dad was in search of a better orange, and took him right to Orlando. Really nice connection. And then you thought, what's up? That was a really great, I just, that took so much longer for me in my head. I'm so sad. I was like, I was like, what? Oh, I'm sad too, but for different reasons.
她爸爸在寻找更好的橙子，这直接把他带到了奥兰多。非常棒的联系。然后你觉得，怎么了？那是一个非常棒的，我只是，这在我的脑海里花了很长时间。我太难过了。我当时就想，我当时想，什么？哦，我也很难过，但原因不同。
Hey, so Orlando, you guys were like, hey, what's the most beautiful, idyllic city in the world? We went, no, no, no, no. We went to, we went there a lot as like, growing up I went there a lot on vacation. And then my dad was like, I love, I just love it here. I love the weather, I love the vibe, I love the people. So we were like, okay, so we moved there
嘿，所以在奥兰多，你们当时就像，嘿，世界上最美丽、最田园诗般的城市是什么？我们去了，不，不，不，不。我们去了，我们经常去那儿，就像成长过程中我经常去那儿度假。然后我爸爸就说，我爱，我只是爱这里。我喜欢这里的天气，我喜欢这里的氛围，我喜欢这里的人。所以我们就想，好吧，所以我们搬到了那里
for about maybe six, eight months, and then. How old were you when you moved? I was eight. Wow. Wow. And my little sister was probably like, oh my gosh, maybe like, I want to say like nine weeks old. Like, it was like, she was really, it was kind of a crazy decision, but we moved.
大概住了六、八个月，然后。你搬过去的时候几岁？我八岁。哇。哇。我小妹妹大概，天哪，也许像，我想说大概九周大。就像，她真的，那是个有点疯狂的决定，但我们搬了。
And then I went to school in Orlando, again, not performing at this point. And then on like, we heard this thing on the radio, me and my dad, and it was like, come to this workshop where you can dance, sing and act. And da da da. My dad was like, that's cool, you should go. Because I was driving him insane on the weekends,
然后我在奥兰多上学，同样，当时并没有表演。然后大概在，我们在收音机里听到了这个东西，我和我爸爸，就像，来参加这个工作坊，你可以跳舞、唱歌和表演。等等等等。我爸爸觉得，这挺酷，你应该去。因为我周末把他快逼疯了，
basically just keep me busy. I didn't have any friends or anything. Singing and dancing. Yeah. And then he took me and then I started going for a bit and then I came back home and I was like, you need to take me, I actually said, which I don't remember saying this,
基本上就是让我保持忙碌。我没有朋友什么的。唱歌和跳舞。是的。然后他带我去，然后我开始去了一会儿，然后我回到家里，我说，你需要带我去，我实际上说的是，虽然我不记得我说过这话，
but my parents are like, you said it. I said, if you take me to Hollywood, I'll make it. And my dad was like, what do you mean? And I was like, I want to go to Hollywood. And I remember having like, I wanted so badly to be in LA and to be an actor. And so the next week, we packed up the car and we drove from Orlando to LA.
但我父母说，你说了。我说，如果你带我去好莱坞，我一定能成功。我爸爸就问，你什么意思？我说我想去好莱坞。我记得当时有那种，我太想去洛杉矶当演员了。所以第二周，我们收拾好车，从奥兰多开车去了洛杉矶。
We didn't have a house, we didn't have anything planned. We stayed in a motel on the side of the highway. What? And I just went to auditions and agents the whole time. And were your siblings like, I don't want to go to Hollywood. I want to stay. Well, you know what's crazy is, no, my brother didn't like school in America.
我们没有房子，我们什么都没计划。我们在高速公路边的一个汽车旅馆住下。什么？我一直在参加试镜和找经纪人。你的兄弟姐妹们当时有没有说，我不想去好莱坞。我想留下来。好吧，你知道疯狂的是什么吗，不，我哥哥不喜欢在美国的学校。
He had a hard time adjusting because he was like 16, so it was a little harder for him. I found it even difficult, like making friends there, just being able to kind of have common ground, especially when you're 60. All these people know each other. They all go to the same kindergarten, the same, you know what I mean?
他很难适应，因为他当时16岁，所以对她来说稍微难一点。我也觉得很难，比如在那里交朋友，只是能够找到共同点，尤其是当你16岁的时候。这些人互相都认识。他们都去同一个幼儿园，同一个，你知道我的意思吗？
And they all know each other. And this is a small town in Florida. So for my brother, I know it was hard for him to adjust. And then- But what was the plan for mom and dad to do in Hollywood? While they, and the other kids, you guys just loaded up the van and went across the country and we'll just figure it out when we get there?
他们互相都认识。而这是佛罗里达的一个小镇。所以对我的哥哥来说，我知道他很难适应。然后——那爸爸妈妈在好莱坞的计划是什么？当他们和别的孩子，你们就把面包车装满然后穿过整个国家，等我们到了再说？
Yeah, pretty much. It was like, we'll figure it out. Great family. I mean, incredible. It's amazing. Figure it out, and like everything was like, if we're together, we're okay. Like, we're always going to be okay.
对，差不多吧。就像，我们会搞定的。伟大的家庭。我是说，难以置信。太棒了。搞定它，就像一切都一样，只要我们在一起，我们就没事。就像，我们总是会没事的。
Right, no matter what. And then you crushed it. And did your parents have jobs lined up along the way? So, no, like my dad, my dad actually, because I was born in Spain, which is- Marbella. Marbella. And so my dad was a really successful real estate agent
对，不管怎样。然后你大获成功。你父母一路上有找好工作吗？所以，没有，就像我爸爸，我爸爸实际上，因为我出生在西班牙，那是——马贝拉。马贝拉。所以我爸爸是个非常成功的房地产经纪人
there, that's what he got into. So he was always like, my dad again, he's kind of a jack of all trades, always been kind of knowing of everything, and it's always been his very talented in that. So when we moved there, it was literally, it was like we have to kind of, now we have to figure this out.
在那里，那就是他从事的行业。所以他总是像，我爸爸再次，他算是个多面手，总是对每样东西都有所了解，而且他在那方面一直很有才华。所以当我们搬到那里时，真的就像，我们必须，现在我们必须弄清楚这一点。
So I went on auditions and- You got an agent right away that got to the auditions? Got an agent. I actually weirdly, maybe the first two weeks, I was going to agents and went to a bunch of different people and I went to Mel's Drive-In for lunch. And James Woods was there. Yeah, okay.
所以我去参加试镜和——你马上就找到了一个能让你去试镜的经纪人？找到一个经纪人。我很奇怪的是，可能前两周，我去找经纪人，去了很多不同的人那里，然后我去了梅尔汽车餐厅吃午饭。詹姆斯·伍兹在那儿。是的，好吧。
And he was like, and I grew up watching, like I didn't watch animation. Like I watched Casino, I watched Moulin Rouge, I watched like these were like, I never ever believed, like I was never one of those kids. Right, right. I loved Disney Channel. You knew who he was.
他说，我是在……长大，我不看动画片。我看了《赌城风云》，我看了《红磨坊》，我看了……这些就像，我从不相信，我从来都不是那种孩子。对，对。我喜欢迪士尼频道。你知道他是谁。
But I did know who he was. He wrote on like the, like, you know, I knew you before you were famous, and it was like the two weeks that I got to LA, and I kind of, I got an agent and did the whole thing. Then I basically just auditioned after, and I was going up for jobs, like, you know, I went for commercials,
但我确实知道他是谁。他在……上写过，就像，你知道的，我在你成名之前就认识你了，那是我到洛杉矶的两周，我差不多，我找了个经纪人，做了一整套流程。然后我基本上就是在那之后不断试镜，我去争取工作，就像，你知道的，我去试镜广告，
but I also went for the BFG, I went, you know, I did Steve Jobs, like the Jobs movie. Like I really went up for everything and got really close. I mean, yeah, like I kind of was... With no training. No, no, I've never, never been trained. Like even when I was going in Orlando, it was never training. like it was always like, do you know what I mean?
但我也去试镜了《圆梦巨人》，我去，你知道的，我拍了《史蒂夫·乔布斯》，就像乔布斯那部电影。我真的去试镜了所有东西，而且非常接近成功。我是说，是的，就像我有点……没有任何训练。不，不，我从来没有，从来没有接受过训练。就像甚至我在奥兰多的时候，也从不是训练。就像总是像，你知道我的意思吗？
It was like, they taught me how to sing, they taught me how to model, which was terrible, like I am not a model. And then they taught me how to dance and I loved it, but of course it was like me like just shaking ass, like had no idea what I was doing. Right, right, right. But the acting thing, I really got,
就像，他们教我唱歌，教我走秀，这太糟糕了，我根本不是个模特。然后他们教我跳舞，我很喜欢，但当然那就像是我在瞎扭屁股，根本不知道自己在干什么。对，对，对。但演戏这件事，我真的得到了，
I could, you know, the monologue stuck in my head and I would think about it for a while. And like, that stuck for me. Right. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Well, what's so amazing to me is, first of all, nerd alert. Like, the rest of the world, I'm such a huge Stranger Things fan.
我能，你知道的，独白卡在我的脑海里，我会想它好一阵子。然后，那个对我来说管用。对。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。好吧，对我来说最神奇的是，首先，书呆子警报。就像世界上的其他人一样，我也是一个巨大的《怪奇物语》粉丝。
And when I watched the first season, I mean, I was just blown away, not only by the show, but of course by you, and I had that thought. I was like, how does this little girl know how to be such a brilliant actor? Without even speaking that much, right? I mean, that first season, there wasn't. That's why I said no training,
当我观看第一季时，我的意思是，我简直惊呆了，不仅是被这部剧，当然还有你，我当时就有那种想法。我就想，这个小女孩怎么能成为一个如此 brilhante (才华横溢) 的演员？甚至不用说太多台词，对吧？我是说，第一季里，没有。这就是为什么我说没有培训，
because it's like, how are you A, so comfortable in front of the camera, B, how did you learn how to do that at such a young age when it takes years and years for other people to do it? Yeah, she's so young and so much better than you already. Like that must have been for you jarring. What the hell is going on? It was very jarring.
因为这就像，A，你在镜头前怎么能这么放松，B，你到底是怎么在那么小的时候就学会做到这一点的，而其他人需要花好几年时间才能做到？是的，她那么年轻，而且已经比你优秀得多了。那对你来说一定很刺耳。到底怎么回事？这非常刺耳。
And then I read for one of the kids as well, on Stranger Things. No, I, I, I, I, I'll be honest, like, you know, when, when we started, like I started auditioning and I got like jobs, like I was like, you know, did NCIS and Modern Family and like, I was kind of just doing these like bit roles, but like still had just so much fun. But when we moved back to London because we eventually couldn't afford
然后我也为《怪奇物语》里的其中一个孩子试镜了。不，我，我，我，我老实说，你知道的，当，当我们开始时，就像我开始试镜并且得到了一些工作，就像我当时觉得，你知道的，拍了《海军罪案调查处》和《摩登家庭》，我差不多就是做这些小角色，但仍然觉得非常有趣。但是当我们搬回伦敦，因为我们最终再也负担不起
to live in LA anymore and like we couldn't we basically was just like we can't do this anymore. So we moved back to London and then I had an audition where I got told like basically I wasn't going to make it. And like in person, this person told me this. Wait, wait, wait, who is the person, you don't have to say their name, but what was their position? They were a casting director.
在洛杉矶的生活了，我们简直就像是再也负担不起了。所以我们搬回了伦敦，然后我接到了一次试镜，被告知，基本上我不会成功了。而且是当面，这个人对我说这话。等等，等等，等等，这个人是谁，你不用说出他们的名字，但他们的职位是什么？他们是一个选角导演。
How old were you at the time? Maybe, gosh, 10. Imagine saying that to a 10 year old. This monster said to you, you know you're not going to make it as an actor. That I was too mature, so I couldn't, I wasn't going to make it because I was too mature. I didn't have that kid-like kind of, that kid-like thing, right? And so I went home and I cried and I cried and I said I'm not going to do it anymore.
你当时几岁？天哪，大概10岁。想象一下对一个10岁的孩子说那种话。这个怪物对你说，你知道你成不了演员的。说我太成熟了，所以我做不到，我不会成功，因为我太成熟了。我没有那种孩子气的那种，那种孩子气的东西，对吧？所以我回家了，我哭了又哭，我说我再也不干了。
Like I don't want to act anymore. My parents were like, my parents, my dad actually. My mom was very much always like, whatever you want, we love ya. You know what I mean? But my dad, he always, Your accent is actually not too bad. Thank you, yeah thank you.
就像我再也不想演戏了。我的父母就像，我的父母，其实是我爸爸。我妈妈一直都是那种，你想要什么，我们就爱你。你知道我的意思吗？但我爸爸，他总是，你的口音其实还不错。谢谢，是的，谢谢。
But yeah, my dad saw something, he always saw that drive in me and was like never letting, like would never let me, you know, slip on that and so he was like, there's this audition in my inbox, let's do the last one and then we're done, like we don't have to do it anymore. And that last audition was Stranger Things. Wow. And so you auditioned from, in England?
但是，是的，我爸爸看出了点什么，他总是看到我骨子里的那股冲劲，就像绝不允许，就像绝不会让我，你知道的，在这方面滑倒，所以他说，我的收件箱里有个试镜，让我们做最后一次，然后我们就结束了，就像我们再也不用做了。而最后那次试镜就是《怪奇物语》。哇。所以你试镜是在，在英国？
On that same day. I was so upset from what happened. On the same day? It was the upset from what happened. On the same day? It was the same day and my dad just like, we set it up and I just went on a blank wall, read the script and was like, what? Like she doesn't have any lines. She just cries.
就在同一天。我对发生的事情太难过了。在同一天？那是对发生的事情感到难过。在同一天？就是同一天，我爸爸就像，我们把它弄好，我就对着一面白墙，读了剧本，然后觉得，什么？就像她没有任何台词。她只会哭。
And she bleeds from her nose. Yeah, but it didn't even say anything. It didn't say like she had superpowers, her name was Levin, nothing like that. It was just like girl, confused, like comes to, doesn't seem like she's kind of human. Like very, very, and I was really vague and I just did what felt natural
而且她流鼻血。是的，但上面甚至什么都没写。上面没说她有超能力，她叫十一，什么都没有。就像是个女孩，很困惑，醒来，看起来好像不太像人类。非常，非常，我很模糊，我只是做了感觉自然的事情
but also used so much of the emotion that had been happening earlier on in that day. Yeah, you were in a really raw place. Really raw, like my, yeah. And did you have long hair then and then of course you shaved it for the first season. Yeah, yeah. I had long hair then? And then of course you shaved for the first season. Yeah. I had long hair and then didn't hear from them for three months
但也运用了那天早些时候发生的那么多情绪。是的，你当时处在一个非常真实Raw的阶段。非常真实，就像我的，是的。你当时留着长头发，然后当然为了第一季你把它剃光了。是的，是的。我当时留着长头发？然后当然为了第一季你剃了光头。是的。我留着长头发，然后三个月没听到他们的消息
and kind of stopped auditioning. Like didn't audition three months and then I got an email saying, hey, you know, the directors of that show that you auditioned for really like you. Can we face... Can we Skype? So... Remember that, guys? I Skyped with them. I Skyped with them. I Skyped with them, yeah I know.
而且差不多停止试镜了。就像三个月没试镜，然后我收到了一封电子邮件，说，嘿，你知道的，你试镜的那部剧的导演真的很喜欢你。我们能面……能Skype吗？所以……还记得那个吗，伙计们？我跟他们Skype了。我跟他们Skype了。我跟他们Skype了，是的，我知道。
I said that the other day and people younger than me were like, I don't know what you're talking about. And I was like, boom. It used to be like, yo, can I Skype you real quick? Do you remember that? Yeah. Sorry, go ahead. So you did a call back video, yeah.
我前几天这么说，比我年轻的人就说，我不知道你在说什么。然后我就说，轰。过去经常是这样的，嘿，我能马上Skype你吗？你还记得吗？是的。抱歉，请继续。所以你做了一个回电视频，对吧？
Yeah, and I did an American accent the whole time because I didn't want them to know I was British. So they had no idea I was British. I basically wanted them to know that I could hold an American accent for that long without them knowing so they could rely on me. So then after the Skype, they were like, can you fly out to LA?
是的，我全程都带着美国口音，因为我不想让他们知道我是英国人。所以他们根本不知道我是英国人。我基本上是想让他们知道，我能保持美国口音那么久而不被他们发现，这样他们就能信任我。所以Skype之后，他们就问，你能飞来洛杉矶吗？
So my dad and I flew out to LA. And this is kind of the weird part. And I said this in my speech on the last day of filming, but we got on the plane and at this point I knew that my character's name was Eleven and I was on row Eleven. And then we got to the hotel, I was on floor Eleven. And everything just seemed really, really weird.
所以我和爸爸飞到了洛杉矶。这有点像奇怪的部分。我在最后一天拍摄的演讲中说过这个，我们上了飞机，此时我知道我的角色的名字叫Eleven（十一），而我在第11排。然后我们到了酒店，我在第11层。一切看起来都真的非常非常奇怪。
Everything felt way too real and kind of positive and optimistic for the first time in kind of like years. And then I went in and I met with them, and I remember it was really weird. They didn't have any lines for me, they just were like, here's a box of clothes. What would you do if you weren't human, if you didn't know who you are,
一切都感觉太真实了，而且多年来第一次感觉那么积极和乐观。然后我进去见他们，我记得真的很奇怪。他们没有给我任何台词，他们只是说，这里有一盒衣服。如果你不是人类，如果你不知道你是谁，
you weren't a normal regular girl, what would you do with this? And I just kept putting the clothes on my head and then just kind of feeling them and I think they were like, shit. She's crazy. We found her. Oh, sorry. Oh, sorry, we found her. Oh, sorry.
你不是一个普通的正常女孩，你会用这个做什么？我只是不断地把衣服往头上一套，然后去感受它们，我想他们当时觉得，靠。她疯了。我们找到她了。哦，抱歉。哦，抱歉，我们找到她了。哦，抱歉。
Oh, sorry, we found her, yeah. That too, they didn't realize that then, but I think they do now. You probably had Sean Levy saying, well, she's wrinkling those clothes. What is she doing with them? But what would you do if you took these clothes? The great Sean Levy.
哦，抱歉，我们找到她了，是的。还有那个，他们当时没意识到，但我想他们现在知道了。你可能听到肖恩·利维说，好吧，她把那些衣服弄皱了。她对它们做什么呢？但如果你拿了这些衣服你会怎么做？伟大的肖恩·利维。
You're so lucky you had him shepherding the whole thing. Don't interrupt my Sean Levy impression. The greatest guy. It was very good, it was very good. How lucky you had him shepherding the whole thing. Don't interrupt my Sean Levy impression. Greatest guy. It was very good, it was very good. And then the next day I got a call in the hotel room as I was leaving back to Heathrow. And then it was the directors and they said,
你能让他带领着这一切真是太幸运了。不要打断我对肖恩·利维的模仿。最棒的家伙。非常棒，非常棒。你能让他带领着这一切真是太幸运了。不要打断我对肖恩·利维的模仿。最棒的家伙。非常棒，非常棒。然后第二天我在酒店房间里接到了一个电话，当时我正准备回希思罗机场。然后是导演们，他们说，
do you want to be our 11 and can you shave your hair off? And I was like, yes and yes. And then literally three months later I was shaving my hair off. That's crazy. Wow. By the way, we've all had those moments. We've all had people say stuff to us in our career where they go, you're not right, you're
你想当我们的十一吗，你能把头发剃光吗？我说，行，没问题。然后仅仅三个月后，我就把头发剃光了。太疯狂了。哇。顺便说一句，我们都经历过那种时刻。我们都经历过别人在我们的职业生涯中对我们说一些话，他们说，你不对，你
never going to be right, or you're not going to... All that kind of stuff. His name is Scotty. But to say... Yeah, and Scotty says that a lot too. And rightfully so. You've got very little talent. But what is particularly repulsive is when an adult says
永远都不会对，或者你不会……所有那种话。他的名字叫斯科蒂。但要说……是的，斯科蒂也经常这么说。理所当然。你没什么才华。但特别令人反感的是，当一个成年人对一个10岁的孩子说那样的话，
that to a 10 year old, and I know it's a professional environment, but in that moment to think that it's okay to say something like that to a 10 year old, to me is absolutely way out of bounds, I think. You know what though, I just feel like growing, like even growing, like that to me, doesn't even like really scrape the surface. Like it's like, growing up in the industry,
我知道这是一个职业环境，但在那种时刻，认为对一个10岁的孩子说那样的话是可以的，在我看来绝对是越界了，我是这么认为的。你知道吗，不过，我只是觉得成长，就像甚至成长，就像对我来说，甚至都还没怎么触及表面。就像，在这个行业里长大，
I, you know, it can get like that. People see you as an adult. And because you- They forget that you're a kid, because you're coming in- Well you're hired, you're hired. So in. Well, you're hired, you're hired. So you're like, you're hired like an adult. You don't work the hours as an adult,
我，你知道的，可能会变成那样。人们把你当成成年人。因为你——他们忘了你是个孩子，因为你进来——好吧，你被雇用了，你被雇用了。所以进去。好吧，你被雇用了，你被雇用了。所以你就像，你像成年人一样被雇用。你的工作时间不像成年人
but you're expected to be there like an adult. Like you're expected to do the job. You're expected, yeah, same responsibilities. Like pretty much everything is the same, you know, except you got to do school three hours a day, really, like that's really it. And so I was so lucky because for me, and I guess that maturity really paid off,
但大家对你的要求就像个成年人一样。就像要求你把工作做好一样。对吧，要求你承担一样的责任。基本上所有事情都一样，你知道的，除了你每天真的得上三个小时的课，真的，基本上就只有这个。所以我真的很幸运，因为对我来说，而且我猜那份成熟确实帮了大忙，
because I was really able to understand the weight of what I was doing, so I was never like, yippity-do-da, what am I doing next? I was always very like, okay, I have my cool time is tomorrow, I need to get eight hours. I was so strict with myself. My parents were always like, they always kind of knew I was like that too, I loved school,
因为我真的能理解我所做事情的分量，所以我从来不会觉得，呀呼，接下来我要做什么？我总是非常清醒，比如，好吧，我明天有休息时间，我需要睡八个小时。我对自己的要求非常严格。我父母也总是……他们其实也一直知道我是那种人，我很喜欢学校，
would really prioritize school. I was just kind of annoyingly one of those kids that just loved work, loved school, just loved really being on set. I was so excited to be done with school so I could have more hours at work because I just loved it. I love that. You know what I noticed, by the way,
会把学校排在非常优先的位置。我就是那种有点烦人的、特别热爱工作、热爱学校、特别喜欢泡在片场的小孩。我当时超级期待快点上完学，这样我就可以在工作上多花点时间了，因为我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。顺便说一句，你们知道我发现了什么吗？
this is, hopefully you don't think this is something bad, but like I've noticed. Here we go. You're in the States right now, United States? My accent. Yes, I was just going to say, you go in and out. It's really cool, actually.
这個，希望你们不觉得这是什么坏事，但我注意到了。来了。你现在在美国对吧，美国？我的口音。对，我正想说呢，你说话时而带英国腔时而带美国腔。其实真的挺酷的。
Well, because you spent a lot of time here and spent a lot of time there. That was such a huge thing for a minute. My whole, I actually call it the accent gate, because it's so frustrating, because that was everywhere. For a second, everyone was talking about my accent, and they had a real problem about it. And I was like, guys, I'm married to an American.
嗯，因为你在这里待了很长时间，也在那边待了很长时间。有一阵子这简直成了一件大事。我整个人——我甚至管它叫“口音门”，因为它太烦人了，那阵子到处都是。有一会儿，每个人都在讨论我的口音，他们对此意见很大。我就想，各位，我嫁给了一个美国人。
When I'm around his family, I immediately go into an American accent. But then I was just in England and then the second I hear my mom and dad's accent, I just go right back into it. It's really cool. And I'm like, you want me to be an actor, you want me to play these characters,
当我跟他家人在一起时，我马上就会换成美国口音。但后来我刚去了英国，只要一听到我爸妈的口音，我马上又切换回去了。这真的很酷。然后我想，你们希望我当演员，希望我扮演这些角色，
but you expect me not to morph into people. What I hear is what I do, I do that, you know? And it's like, it's all part of it. And I'm just like, on my own. Wherever you are, you're going to be influenced by your location. Just like you are. You're doing it right now, Will.
但你们却期望我不会融入到周围人当中。我听到什么就会模仿什么，我就是这样，你知道吗？这都是其中的一部分。而且我就觉得，随我便吧。无论你在哪里，你都会受到你所在环境的影响。就像你们一样。你现在不就在这样吗，威尔。
Yeah, of course. With your English accent. Sean's about to move onto Old Queen Road, and then he's going to morph into that. So like everybody. There's a nice flat over there. I'm really eyeing. What are you doing, dude?
对，当然。带着你的英国腔。肖恩马上就要搬到老女王街去了，然后他也会变成那样。就像所有人一样。那边有个不错的公寓。我正盯着呢。你在干嘛，老兄？
What are you doing? Millie, if so, closing the loop on the childhood start thing, what would you say to that 10 year old starting out now, now that you know a lot since then, what do you think you could say to that 10 year old that would help her kind of cut some corners?
你在干嘛？米莉，如果是这样的话，给童星这个话题画个句号，对于现在的那个10岁刚出道的自己，既然你现在已经懂了很多，你觉得你可以对那个10岁的小女孩说些什么，能帮她少走一些弯路？
You know, like, I'll be honest, like I really think that like I am so glad like everything happened to me. Like even the shitty stuff that I know kind of was hard at the time that I was going through, like I needed to go through it. Like, because I really am am a different person from it. And I know it sounds silly, but I started this when I was eight years old, and I'm turning
你知道吗，说实话，我真的觉得，我超级庆幸发生在我身上的这一切。甚至包括那些我知道在当时经历时挺艰难的糟糕事情，我也觉得我必须经历它们。因为我真的通过这些变成了一个不同的人。我知道这听起来很傻，但我8岁就开始拍戏了，我下周就要
21 next week. And I- Same. Happy birthday. Same. Thank you. We're all 21. We're all turning 21.
21岁了。我也是。生日快乐。我也是。谢谢。我们都21岁了。我们都要21岁了。
Yeah, like to Jason, looking back now, what is the one thing or several things that you wish you knew that you wish you knew like that that you go You know what happened to me when I was 11 or 12 or 13 or 14 I'm gonna make sure that never happens again Yeah, I didn't need to worry about this as much or conversely to think so you don't focus on a negative I wish there was something that I did more of. You know what I mean? Right, yeah, no, totally. I think for me, honestly, the only thing I would say to her
对，就像对杰森来说，现在回想起来，你最希望自己早知道的一件事或几件事是什么？你会想：“你知道吗，当我11、12、13或14岁时发生在我身上的那些事，我一定要确保它绝不再发生。”或者“是的，我其实没必要为这个那么担心。”反过来说，为了不总是盯着消极的一面，我希望自己当时能多做一点什么。你知道我的意思吗？对，对，完全是这样。我觉得对我来说，说实话，我唯一会对自己说的话就是——
is like, your parents, you're good. Like, don't worry. Like, they got you. No matter what. Lean into that as much as possible. Because when you're a kid, you try and, you know, you want to do everything on your own, and you're trying your best. But like, no. I am so reliant on my family.
“你的父母，你们很好。别担心。他们罩着你呢。无论如何都行。”尽量去依靠他们。因为当你还是个孩子的时候，你会试着……你知道的，你想自己搞定一切，你也在尽力做到最好。但其实，不用。我很依赖我的家人。
And like, honestly, they have kept my feet on the ground. And I just would probably say to them, or say to her, because I know she was maybe a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more my feet on the ground and I just would probably say, or say to her that like, because I know she was maybe a little bit scared about growing up and making sure that- Well she's going to be scared that you're there
老实说，是他们让我双脚踏实地。我大概会对自己说，或者对当年的那个她——因为我知道她当时可能有点害怕长大，想要确保——好吧，她本来就会害怕你会突然出现，
in the first place because you're appearing out of nowhere as your older self. That's true, she would be terrified. Give her a little space, okay? But no, what I was like, I feel like... She's got to absorb all that. I feel like, I feel like what's cool though, is that when I was younger, I was so afraid
因为你作为一个成年的自己毫无征兆地从天而降。也对，她会吓坏的。给她一点空间，好不好？不过说真的，我觉得……她得消化所有这些。我觉得，我觉得挺酷的一点是，当我更年轻的时候，我非常害怕
of becoming those infamous child stars that just go awry. Jason Beatty. Right, those, exactly, Jason. That's a huge story that I know is viral. Yeah, cautionary tale, we call him. Exactly. No, but you know, and it's a deep fear because it happens. And by the way, you're constantly reminded of it in an interview. At like 12, 13 years old, people would be like,
自己会变成那些声名狼藉、最后误入歧途的童星。杰森·贝蒂。对，那些，没错，杰森。我知道那是个流传很广的大新闻。对，我们管这叫前车之鉴。没错。不，但你知道的，这是一种深深的恐惧，因为这种事确实会发生。而且顺便说一句，在采访中你总是会被不断提醒这一点。在大约12、13岁的时候，人们会问：
what do you think about this person and their journey? Do you feel like you can relate to that? And trying to trick me, and I would go home and think, what if that happened to me? What if I lost touch of reality and that's so scary? And it really was a deep fear and honestly, I just again would tell myself, you're not going to be like that.
“你对这个人以及他的经历怎么看？你觉得你能感同身受吗？”他们试图套我话，我回家后就会想：如果这种事发生在我身上怎么办？如果我与现实脱节了，那该多可怕啊！这真的是一种深深的恐惧，老实说，我还是会告诉自己：你不会变成那样。
You have your family to guide you. Yeah, just anchor yourself into your family, into the things that matter, into your values. Yeah, but everything else I think I'm so grateful I went through. It's all great. Yeah, you know, and you would, I know that there are some things
你有你的家人引导你。对，只要把自己锚定在家人身上，锚定在重要的事情上，锚定在你的价值观上。对，但对于其他所有经历，我都心怀感激。这一切都很棒。对，你知道的，而且你会……我知道有些事情
I wish I could maybe change and stuff, but honestly, like, I'm happy I went through it, and like now I can just use that as reference. You know what, I'm just remembering, we met when you were a kid. We were at some thing, do you remember this? You were like, you had just started doing stranger met when you were a kid. We were at some thing. Do you remember this? You were like, you had just started doing stranger things.
我可能希望去改变之类的，但老实说，我很高兴我经历了这一切，现在我可以把这些作为参考。你知道吗，我突然想起来，我们第一次见面时你还是个孩子。我们在某个活动上，你还记得吗？你当时……你刚刚开始拍《怪奇物语》……我们在某个活动上。你还记得吗？你当时……你刚刚开始拍《怪奇物语》。
You were like 12, you were with your mom and we were at like some event. Yeah, guess what, Will? She's got no idea what you're talking about. I know, she doesn't. Hey, no, no, no, I will say this, and actually it's so interesting because Ariana Grande, I think, just talks about it.
你当时大概12岁，跟你妈妈在一起，我们是在某个活动上。对，你猜怎么着，威尔？她根本不知道你在说些什么。我知道，她不知道。嘿，不，不，不，我得说，其实这挺有趣的，因为爱莉安娜·格兰德好像刚谈到过这个。
But like, I feel that I can't remember a lot of my childhood. Especially when Will Arnett's a part of it. You know, she starts like a, like a dial tone. Where were we? I don't know. It was at some, like at some professional engagement. But I, but you know. Because out of the gate,
但我觉得，我不记得自己童年的很多事情了。尤其是当威尔·阿奈特也是其中一部分的时候。你知道的，她开始像个……像个拨号音一样。我们在哪儿？我不知道。那是在某个，在某种专业的活动上。但是，但是你知道。因为一开播，
Stranger Things was such, so massive. It was overnight. Right away. And I'm sure, I don't want to put words in your mouth, but I'm sure all of that, then you get all this attention, everybody wanting to do interviews and people meeting people, it just becomes a whirlwind and foggy. Yeah, sometimes people will say things to me and I'm like,
《怪奇物语》就太火爆了。一夜爆红。马上就火了。而且我确信——我不想替你做决定，但我确信所有这些……接着你得到了所有这些关注，每个人都想采访你，每个人都想见你，这简直成了一场龙卷风，让人晕头转向。对，有时人们会对我说一些话，然后我就想：
oh yeah, I did meet that person. I forget who I met. Yeah, you can't remember it all. I'm forgettable, I'm very forgettable, I will give you that. No, no, no, no, but seriously, I forget who I've met. Yeah, you can't remember at all. I'm forgettable. I'm very forgettable. I will give you that. No, no, no, no. But like, seriously, like, I... And like, I know people forget things when they're like, you know, older because they have kids, like, or when they're a kid, they forget things. But I...
哦对，我确实见过那个人。我都忘了我见过谁。对，你不可能什么都记得。我这人记性不好，特别容易忘事，这点我承认。不，不，不，不，但说真的，我都忘了我见过谁。对，你不可能全记住。我这人记性不好。我特别容易忘事。这点我承认。不，不，不，不。但是，说真的，我……而且我知道人们年纪大一点的时候会忘事，你知道的，因为他们有了孩子；或者当他们还是个孩子时，他们也会忘事。但我……
Jason doesn't remember who we are. I'm the worst. But I think you're right, Sean. Like, I definitely, you right, Sholan. I went on a vacation right before Stranger Things came out and I had 25 followers and I don't even remember what my fucking username was. I didn't even really know what Instagram was. And then the next night, so we were driving to,
杰森连我们是谁都不记得了。我最健忘了。但我觉得你说得对，肖恩。对，你说的对，肖恩。我在《怪奇物语》上映前不久去度假，当时我只有25个粉丝，我甚至都不记得我那该死的用户名叫什么了。我当时甚至不太知道Instagram是什么。然后第二天晚上，我们在开车去……
I think Palm Springs or something, and then I woke up from the nap, and I woke up and I had a million followers. My phone broke, and I looked at my dad and he was driving, I was like, what happened? And he's like, I think this show is going to be really, really big. And I was like, wow. And I remember I turned my phone, I was asking my mom, can you turn this off? I don't know how to even work this. And we got to the Palm Springs Hotel, to which the whole staff started freaking out,
我猜是棕榈泉或者什么地方，然后我从小睡中醒来，我醒来时已经有了一百万粉丝。我的手机死机了，我看着正在开车的爸爸说：“发生什么事了？”他说：“我觉得这部剧要彻底大火了。”我就想：“哇。”我记得我翻转手机，问我妈：“你能把它关掉吗？我都不知道这东西怎么用。”等我们到了棕榈泉的酒店时，全体员工都吓坏了，
because I still had a shaved head, and I still looked like 11. And people were freaking out, and I was like, oh my God. So it was actually over the course of a drive. 63 million followers. You have 63 million followers? Wow.
因为我当时还剃着光头，看起来还是十一（Eleven）的样子。大家都在尖叫，我就想：哦天哪。所以这其实是在一次车程中发生的。6300万粉丝。你有6300万粉丝？哇。
On what platform? Instagram. Is that Instagram? On Instagram, I think. Good Lord. Wow. You're looking good. Looks nothing like what I'm showing right now.
在哪个平台？Instagram。那是Instagram吗？大概是在Instagram上吧。我的天哪。哇。你现在状态很好。看起来跟我现在展示的完全不一样。
No, but wow, you look amazing. Thank you. That's insane. Well now, so then growing up with all of these sort of interesting pressures, to put it kindly, as Stranger Things was exploding, was it helpful to have other kids on the show? That you guys could sort of go through that together.
不，但是哇，你看起来太棒了。谢谢。这太疯狂了。那么现在，伴随着《怪奇物语》的爆红，伴随着所有这些——委婉点说——有趣的压力长大，剧里有其他同龄的小演员，这对你会有帮助吗？你们可以一起经历这一切。
And now that it's over, is there a, how do you, that's like, those are brothers of yours that you have to like say goodbye to? Like, is it strange? Is it hard? It is strange. I think, you know, I'll be honest, like, you know, the kids, because there's so many boys, they, it was so great, because I know that they had such great camaraderie in their kind of brotherhood of growing up and being teen boys, you know, in this huge hit show.
而现在剧要结束了，有没有一种……你怎么看待……就像那是你必须说再见的兄弟一样？这感觉奇怪吗？这很难吗？这确实很奇怪。我想，你知道的，说实话，你知道的，孩子们——因为有很多男孩——他们……这真的很棒，因为我知道他们在那种一起长大、作为十几岁男孩的兄弟情谊中度过了很棒的时光，你知道的，在这部大热剧里。
For me, my journey was a little bit different. Like, you know, I feel like as a woman and as a young girl, I just went through it a bit differently in terms of the things that I was wearing and the kinds of things I was kind of not- Interested in. Subject to experiencing, but just a bit more, people would ask me very different questions than they would ask them. That's the way it felt.
对我的经历来说，稍微有点不同。你知道的，我觉得作为一个女性和一个年轻女孩，我在穿着打扮以及经历的事情上，经历的方式有点不太一样，比如那些我没有——感兴趣的。经历的主题，但更偏向于……人们会问我一些跟问他们完全不同的问题。感觉就是这样。
It was very much like they could just be them and I kind of had to put some, like put a show on a little bit more. Right, right, yeah. Which was just a bit, it was just my different experience. But again, not like a bad experience, but just different. And I was, I am so close with the boys. Like I love them and I have been really lucky, again,
很大程度上就像他们可以做自己，而我则需要更多地去演一出戏。对，对，没错。这只是有点……这只是我不同的经历。但再次说明，并不是说是一次糟糕的经历，只是不同而已。而且我和这些男孩们关系非常好。我很爱他们，我又一次觉得自己非常幸运，
to have that experience with them and saying goodbye to them was really, really emotional. For all of us. Yeah, I saw that last day on the set. I almost started crying. It was incredible. Your speech was great. Thank you.
能和他们有过那段经历，跟他们说再见真的、真的很情绪化。我们所有人都是。对，我看到了在片场的最后一天。我差点哭出来。那太不可思议了。你的发言太棒了。谢谢。
It was a lot longer than what I put on Instagram but I really wanted to, you know, I love the boys and I love the cast but the crew, like, I grew up with these people, and most of them were like my parents. Now what about, let's get to David Harbour. I'm about to start a project with David Harbour. Any hints, any tips, anything to get ready to enjoy,
比我发在Instagram上的要长得多，但我真的很想……你知道的，我爱这些男孩，我也爱演员们，但剧组的工作人员，我是跟这些人一起长大的，他们中的大多数就像我的父母一样。那么，让我们聊聊大卫·哈伯。我马上要和David Harbour合作一个项目。有什么暗示、有什么小贴士、有什么准备工作能让我好好享受，
anything to watch out for? It's just you and I talking. Here we go. David, so David and I, he played my dad in the show and like, he and I had, I would say, I would honestly say this, the most real relationship. Yeah, yeah. Like.
有什么需要注意的吗？现在就你和我聊天。来吧。大卫，大卫和我，他在剧中扮演我的父亲，我和他之间有——我可以说，我老实说，有着最真实的父女关系。对，对。就像。
I hear he's fantastic. He and I had like a really, really transparent relationship where we're very, very honest, can be brutal with each other, but really good friends. And I think what is so amazing about him, he, everything's about your heart. He sees your heart, he knows what you want,
我听说他超级棒。我和他之间有一种非常、非常透明的关系，我们非常、非常诚实，甚至会对彼此很不客气，但我们是真正的好朋友。我觉得他最了不起的地方在于，他的一切都关乎你的内心。他能看到你的内心，他知道你想要什么，
he wants to find the beauty in everything, and the beauty in the scene, and he wants to find it and he always Gave me that black look with JB I'm all heart good. Good luck. I'm finding any beauty in that heart We'll be right back All right back to the show You know, it's so amazing. I'm sorry, at the beginning you said Millie or Millie Bobby?
他想在一切事物中找到美，在每一场戏中找到美，他总是……他给了我一个黑脸，对JB来说，我全心全意，好吧。祝你在那颗心中找到任何美吧。我们马上回来。好的，欢迎回到节目中。你知道，太神奇了。对不起，你在开头说的是米莉还是米莉·博比？
Millie. You can call me Mill. Whatever you want. You got to call her Millie Bobby Brown. I think you have to do the full. Miss Brown. And then Bon Jovi. Miss Brown.
米莉。你叫我米尔就行。随你便。你得叫她米莉·博比·布朗。我觉得你得叫全名。布朗小姐。还有邦·乔维。布朗小姐。
And then Bon Jovi. What's really cool is that a lot of people with your success at such an early age would probably feel like, great, I did it, now I don't have to, whatever, I can rest on my laurels and whatever. But you just keep going with incredible work and, like Jason said, at the beginning with this new line of products that you have and it's really impressive that you still have a drive and a curiosity and a purpose. Have you got a big movie coming out this year too?
还有邦·乔维。真的很酷的一点是，很多人在这么小的年纪取得你这样的成就后，可能会觉得：太棒了，我做到了，现在我不用再……管他呢，我可以吃老本了之类的。但你一直在以惊人的作品继续前行，就像杰森刚才说的，带着你拥有的这个全新产品线，你依然保持着驱动力、好奇心和目标感，这真的让人印象深刻。你今年也有一部大电影要上映吧？
Don't you have a big movie coming out? Oh, yes. Let's talk about electric. State. State. Oh, yeah, and Pratt's in that too, right? Yes. Yes.
你是不是有一部大电影要上映？哦，对。我们来聊聊《电幻国度》。国度。哦，对，帕特也参演了对吧？对。对。
And then you have those upstart directors, the Russo brothers, I believe. I know. Like, oh, how did you get through that? Oh, these guys. I was terrible. These fucking guys. These guys.
然后你还有那些新锐导演，罗素兄弟，如果我没记错的话。我知道。就像，哦，你是怎么挺过来的？哦，这几个家伙。我太差劲了。这群混蛋。这群家伙。
No, I honestly like, you know, I walked onto that set and it's like a well-oiled machine. They, it's like. Yeah, I mean. And then that Pratt guy. No, I mean, Pratt's a different story. Pratt is like, I don't even under... His thing, which I love, is like, he always says, and I love this, he'll go like, if you come to set in a bad mood, what are you, having a hard time living your dream?
不，老实说，我走上那个片场时，感觉就像一台运转良好的机器。他们……就像。对，我是说。还有那个帕特。不，我是说，帕特是另一回事。帕特是那种——我甚至不理解……他的口头禅——我很喜欢——他总是说，我很喜欢这个，他会说：如果你带着糟糕的心情来到片场，怎么着，过着梦想中的生活让你觉得很艰难吗？
And I'm always like, I love that. He comes to set and he is truly so grateful and honored to be there and to fulfill that role. And he taught me a lot, because I love, listen, I love work, but you know, you go through your days where you're like, for fuck's sake, I'm having a bad day. But he saw, and he brought sun every day, it was always positivity, it was always funny, it was always like, just sun,
我总是想：我太喜欢这个了。他来到片场时，真的是满怀感激和荣幸能来到这里并完成那个角色。他教会了我很多，因为我很喜欢——听着，我很热爱工作，但你知道的，总会经历一些日子，你会想：他妈的，我今天心情真糟糕。但他看到了，他每天都带来阳光，总是充满正能量，总是很有趣，就像……纯粹的阳光，
and the Russos also are so great at that, like keeping such a great spirited set. I saw the movie, it's really good. Thank you. Yeah, I loved it. Thank you, I loved, yeah, I mean the movie, like immediately I was so excited to do it, because I had never done anything like this,
罗素兄弟也特别擅长这一点，能让片场保持如此高昂的精神状态。我看过这部电影，真的很好。谢谢。对，我很喜欢。谢谢，我很喜欢，我是说这部电影，我一看到就超级兴奋能参与，因为我从来没拍过这样的作品，
and also my dream was to work with the Russo brothers, so like I, you know. What did Joe Russo call you? You know he calls everybody by their last name, or he'll go like hey, hey Brad Go sit down here and then move to the did he call you Brown? He didn't he calls me Mills. That's it Like he sometimes he doesn't even bother to get up out of his chair He'll just go feel I love when he does that so he'll be like, you know what once he said to me
而且我的梦想就是和罗素兄弟合作，所以……乔·罗素管你叫什么？你知道他管所有人都叫姓氏，或者他会说：嘿，嘿，布朗，去那儿坐下，然后转到……他叫你布朗了吗？没有，他叫我米尔斯。就这样。有时候他甚至懒得从椅子上站起来。他就会说，米尔。我喜欢他那样，所以他会说，你知道吗，有一次他对我说：
I come into his tent and I'm like, hey guys, did you, his tent. And I'll be like, hey, did you see that? And he's like, yeah. And then he goes, we're getting cannolis. If you do this take, you get a cannoli. And I was just like, fuck yeah. And I, because he's so Italian. And I just remember, like, he gets his assistant, their assistant comes in with just like basically a box of cannolis and everyone's so Italian. And I just remember like he gets like his assistant,
我走进他的帐篷，说：嘿，伙计们，你们……他的帐篷。我会说：嘿，你们看到那个了吗？他说：对。然后他说：我们要去吃卡诺里卷（cannoli）。如果你拍好这条，你就能吃一个卡诺里卷。我当时就想：他妈的太棒了。我，因为他太意大利了。我只记得，他让他的助理……他们的助理走进来，端着基本上满满一盒卡诺里卷，每个人都……太意大利了。我只记得他让他的助理……
their assistant comes in with just like basically a box of cannolis and everyone's just eating. His name is Anthony. No, not Ant. No, Anthony. Not Ant. Ant. Ant, hey Ant.
他们的助理走进来，端着基本上满满一盒卡诺里卷，每个人都在吃。他叫安东尼。不，不是安特。不，安东尼。不是安特。安特，嘿，安特。
By the way, you go in there and you'd be like, hey Joe, what are you thinking? He's like, hang on a second, I'm just doing my fantasy football. I'm like, what? Yeah, Joe's doing his fantasy lineup and Anthony's actually running shit. No, no, on a second, I'm just doing my fantasy football. I'm like, what? No. Joe's doing his fantasy lineup and Anthony's actually running shit. No, no, on Electric State, he was addicted to TikTok
顺便说一句，你走进去然后说：嘿，乔，你在想什么？他说：等一下，我正在搞我的梦幻足球。我说：什么？对，乔在搞他的梦幻足球阵容，而安东尼实际上在苦哈哈地干活。不，不，等一下，我正在搞我的梦幻足球。我说：什么？不。乔在搞他的梦幻足球阵容，而安东尼实际上在苦哈哈地干活。不，不，在拍《电幻国度》时，他沉迷于TikTok，
and we actually had to have a sit down talk about it. Of course he was. Did you teach him any dances? No, I don't have TikTok. I do not like TikTok, so I am not a fan of TikTok. So I, cause I just don't do this. Interesting, interesting. Walk me through that a little bit.
我们甚至不得不为此专门坐下来谈了一谈。他当然沉迷了。你教过他什么舞蹈吗？不，我没有TikTok。我不喜欢TikTok，所以我不是TikTok的粉丝。所以，因为我根本不用这个。有趣，有趣。跟我详细说说这个。
We've made some news right there. I just, I have a hard time with social media. I don't like social media. Thank you. Which is actually bringing it back. Says the girl with 63 million followers. It's not her fault they follow her. I don't have Instagram.
我们刚刚爆了个大新闻。我只是……我对社交媒体有点应付不来。我不喜欢社交媒体。谢谢。这话居然出自一个拥有6300万粉丝的女孩之口。别人关注她又不是她的错。我没有Instagram。
I don't have Instagram on my phone. Someone else does it for me. And I'll take a picture and then I'll send it to someone and then they'll post it for me. I love this. I think that's really healthy. I think that, you know, I've been a proponent of everybody taking a pause on social media.
我手机里没有Instagram。别人帮我打理。我拍张照片，然后发给某个人，他们帮我发出去。我喜欢这样。我觉得这非常健康。我觉得，你知道的，我一直支持每个人对社交媒体按暂停键。
I think it's really dangerous. But, and I think it's really good for you. But I'm not like, it's not like just TikTok. Like TikTok, I think, is a platform where I see, I used to see more negative than I did positive. So I was like, okay, I'm out. I don't want to be a part of that. So I felt the same thing with Instagram, so I did positive. So I was like, okay, I'm out. I don't want to be a part of that. So I felt the same thing with Instagram,
我觉得这真的很危险。而且我觉得这对你很有好处。但我不只是针对TikTok。就像TikTok，我觉得它是一个平台，我在上面看到的负面内容比正面内容多得多。所以我就想：好吧，我不玩了。我不想参与其中。我在Instagram上也感觉到了同样的东西，所以我不玩了。所以我就想：好吧，我不玩了。我不想参与其中。我在Instagram上也感觉到了同样的东西，
so I deleted that. So now I have no social media on my phone, so I don't get notifications about what's happening in the world, who's dating who. Who's you know. And I just don't enjoy it, so I am out of the loop. But. However, Joe.
所以我把它删了。所以现在我手机上没有任何社交媒体，我不会收到关于世界上正在发生什么、谁在和谁约会、谁在……的通知。我就是不喜欢，所以我跟外界脱节了。不过。然而，乔。
He's not. Has a problem. He's not, he had a problem, and I had to bring it up to him. He knew that his scrolling for hours was becoming a huge issue and his algorithm was so weird. Like his like. Would he forget to yell cut?
他可没有。他有问题。他没有，他有问题，我不得不当面指出他。他知道自己连续刷几个小时手机已经成了一个大问题，而且他的算法太诡异了。比如他的点赞……他会忘记喊停吗？
No, never that bad. But like, it was like, I would like, we would be setting up a shot and he's just like in there, in his amazing chair that I'm just scrolling away Chuckling to himself and I was just like Anthony's out there setting frames Yeah, Anthony's not more responsible than Joe Joe's just rolling Shopping for a wheelchair so he doesn't ever have to stand up All right, let's get back into this interview
不，从没那么糟糕。但感觉就像……我们在布景时，他就坐在那把超棒的椅子上，不停地刷着手机，自己在那儿偷笑。我就想：安东尼还在外面摆镜头呢。对，安东尼可比乔负责任多了。乔只是在滚动屏幕，在网上物色轮椅，这样他就能永远不用站起来了。好了，让我们回到这个访谈中。
Millie you've got so much going on. I want to talk about the children. I want to talk about your 10 children. What are their names? So, okay, so basically I have Bobby, Marley, Max, Winnie, Agnes, Rigby, Pookie, Juno. Did I say Dorothy yet? No. Nope, Dorothy and I say Dorothy yet? No.
米莉，你身上有太多事情要忙了。我想聊聊那些“孩子”。我想聊聊你的10个孩子。他们叫什么名字？好吧，基本上我有：博比、马利、马克斯、威妮、阿格尼斯、里格比、普基、朱诺。我刚才说多萝西了吗？没有。没有，多萝西，我刚才说多萝西了吗？没有。
Nope, Dorothy, and I'm missing one, Jimmy. Sweet Jimmy. So I have 10 dogs, but then I have- But you've got a couple of turtles and a donkey. So I have, so I live on a farm, so I take care of, I have a horse, four ponies, two cows, five goats, yeah, I mean. Are you in the UK?
没有，多萝西，我还漏了一个，吉米。可爱的吉米。所以我有10只狗，但是我还——但你还有几只乌龟和一头驴。所以我有，我住在农场里，所以我照顾……我有一匹马、四匹小马、两头牛、五只山羊，对，我是说。你在英国吗？
I'm in Georgia. Oh, wow. Come on. Wait, but did the dogs, did the 10 dogs stay in the house or out of the house? Yeah, so the 10 dogs are in the house, and then I have, so I have the farm animals, but the farm animals, I didn't,
我在佐治亚州。哦，哇。来吧。等等，那这些狗，这10只狗是住在屋里还是屋外？对，这10只狗是住在屋里的，然后我有……我有农场动物，但农场动物，我不是……我养农场动物，实际上，我养驴只是因为我遇到了郊狼的问题，而郊狼非常怕驴。哇。
I only got farm animals, really, I only got a donkey, because I had a coyote problem, and coyotes are terrified of donkeys. Wow. Is that right? Mm-hmm, so I got a donkey. Then I basically started rescuing farm animals. So basically, there would be a farm, and here in Georgia, there's goats on the side of the street,
是这样吗？嗯哼，所以我养了一头驴。然后我基本上就开始救助农场动物了。所以基本上，在佐治亚州这里，你会看到街边有山羊，然后你会想：搞什么鬼，谁能把它们带走？我基本上就会把这些动物接回家，然后用奶瓶喂它们。我基本上就会把这些动物接回家，然后用奶瓶喂它们。所以我会用奶瓶喂养这些农场动物。
and you're like, what the hell, who can take these? And I would just basically take these animals, and then I bottle-fed them. And I would just basically take these animals and then I bottle fed them. So I would bottle feed these farm animals. A goat came onto set of Electric State every day. I had to bottle feed my goat Eminem for every four hours. Like the candy or the rapper? The rapper, because he's the goat.
有一只山羊每天都去《电幻国度》的片场。我每四个小时就得用奶瓶喂我的山羊阿姆斯特丹（Eminem）。像糖果还是那个说唱歌手？说唱歌手，因为他是山羊（GOAT，史上最佳）。
Hence the name. Love it. Stupid Will. Okay, sorry. I want to get back, can we just get back for one second to the donkeys are some sort of a coyote. The Terran. Now is that true?
所以才叫这个名字。太棒了。笨蛋威尔。好吧，抱歉。我想回到……我们能回到刚才那头驴对抗某种郊狼的话题上吗？真的吗？
Cause you know we've got massive coyote issues here in Los Angeles. It is true. That's why people, well that's why people often ask Sean to come over cause they recognize what a jackass he is. Hell. Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow. What about horses?
因为你知道我们在洛杉矶有严重的郊狼问题。这是真的。这就是为什么人们……这也是为什么人们经常叫肖恩过去，因为他们认出他是个蠢驴（jackass）。见鬼。哇，哇，哇，哇，哇。那马呢？
Are the coyotes, they don't care about the horses? No. It's a donkey. It is a donkey. A donkey, they actually are quite aggressive, which sounds kind of weird, but if a donkey like saw a dog, the donkey would try and kill the dog. It is a very, very much like, if you Google it, like you will see that like donkeys are very serious.
郊狼……它们不在乎马吗？不。是驴。必须是驴。驴其实相当具有攻击性，听起来可能有点奇怪，但如果驴看到狗，驴会试图杀死那只狗。这非常、非常……如果你去谷歌一下，你会发现驴子真的很厉害。
I'm going down, I'm going to get on a YouTube wormhole here and watch donkey fights with dogs. I think Arnold has a donkey. He does, he does. He does, right? Yeah. Who does? Arnold Schwarzenegger.
我要去，我要陷入YouTube的兔子洞，去看驴和狗打架了。我记得阿诺德也有一头驴。他有，他有。他有的，对吧？谁有？阿诺德·施瓦辛格。
Yeah, I think. Schwarzenegger's got a donkey? Yeah, he has it in the house. Yeah. Yeah, but Jake had to kind of drill the line at some point because we were bringing in these goats that sleep in our bed and they're in diapers. What?
对，我想。施瓦辛格有一头驴？对，他把它养在屋里。对。对，但杰克在某个时候不得不划清界限，因为我们带回了那些睡在我们床上、还穿着纸尿裤的山羊。什么？
What? You got a diapered goat in the bed? Yeah, they sleep with me at night because I have to take care of, because they're babies. Girl, you so crazy. They're, they were basically babies and so I would sleep with them, and Jake, they would be in the middle, and they are so cute, and I basically,
什么？你床上有一只穿纸尿裤的山羊？对，它们晚上跟我一起睡，因为我必须照顾……因为它们还是婴儿。女孩，你也太疯狂了。它们……它们基本上还是婴儿，所以我跟它们一起睡，而杰克……它们睡在中间，它们太可爱了，我基本上……
Jake would get up and do a shift, and then I would get up and do a shift. Yeah, she would do that actually. I had it, I had like Norman, Lammy, Eminem, I did the same thing with my cows. But they would wear a diaper in the bed with you. You've got to lose yourself, you own it, the moment you never get it back.
杰克会起床值一个班，然后我起床值一个班。对，她真的会这么做。我有……我有诺曼、兰米、阿姆斯特丹，我对我的牛也做过同样的事。但它们在床上跟你一起睡时还穿着纸尿裤。你必须抛自我，全情投入，错过了那个时刻就再也找不回去了。
Ha ha ha ha. It's so stupid, dumb, and cheap, you're fired. Millie, please continue. That was, I liked that a lot. Wait, but you would have to change their diapers and all that stuff. Yeah, well, and then people started, in my community, people started thinking I was pregnant
哈哈哈哈。太蠢、太滑稽、太便宜了，你被解雇了。米莉，请继续。那段挺搞笑的。等等，那你还得给它们换纸尿裤和所有这些东西。对，然后人们开始……在我的社区里，人们开始以为我怀孕了，
because I was buying bottles and nappies and all the things. Yeah. So then they reach around like eight weeks old and then they're full grown and they have horns and they're they're wanting to go outside so then I have them outside and then we put them outside and then It's not a good combo horny in a diaper Speaking of Scotty do you think All right, so then they're outside and then you move on to another baby animal in the bed Ah, what a, what a, what a wow. All right, so then they're outside and then you move on to another baby animal in the bed.
因为我一直在买奶瓶、纸尿裤和所有这些东西。对。所以它们长到大约八周大左右，然后就完全长大了，长出了角，而且它们想去户外，所以我就把它们放到户外，然后我们把它们放到户外，然后……长角加纸尿裤可不是个好组合。说到斯科蒂，你觉得……好吧，所以它们在户外了，然后你又把另一只动物宝宝弄到床上去？
Yes? Yeah, so to go on to, so then I have, I have 20, okay, you're not actually gonna, I have 25 dogs, but on top of the 10. So the 25 live outside, but they have, I have a shed and I rescue dogs off of the street, and from high-asian age- Jake is on board with all of this nonsense?
对吧？对，所以继续说……然后我有20只……好吧，你可能不会相信……除了那10只之外，我还有25只狗。所以这25只狗住在外面，但它们有……我有一个棚子，我从街上和高杀率收容所救助狗狗。杰克对这一堆乱七八糟的事毫无异议吗？
Yeah, I mean, I kind of like, this is like, he knows how much I like love animals, like I would like- Yeah, but you can't have all those animals- No, so we drew the line, actually, he said no more, but I have to obviously have my dog Winnie in the bed, like that's like, we're not compromising on that. Actually, he said no more, but I have to obviously have my dog Winnie in the bed. That's like, we're not compromising on that. It is a deal breaker.
对，我是说，我基本上……他知道我有多么热爱动物，所以我会……对，但你不能养那么多动物啊——不，所以我们划了底线，实际上，他说不能再多了，但我必须让我的狗威妮睡在床上，这是……我们在这一点上没有妥协。实际上，他说不能再多了，但我必须让我的狗威妮睡在床上。这是……我们在这一点上没有妥协。这是绝对不能退让的底线。
But he does allow farm animals, and he enjoys it as much as I do. We just had two babies, two baby, baby puppies, neonatal puppies come to us right before Christmas, and their mom got taken away so they needed to be bottle fed. They weren't taken to the bottle. So Jake and I every four hours would tube feed these babies in an incubator.
但他确实允许养农场动物，而且他跟我一样享受其中。我们刚刚迎来了两只小狗，两只刚出生不久的、处于新生儿期的小狗，在圣诞节前夕来到了我们这里，它们的妈妈被带走了，所以它们需要用奶瓶喂养。它们不会用奶瓶。所以杰克和我每四个小时就在保温箱里用管子喂养这些小宝贝。
Oh wow. I thought you were going to say that you had to bird feed them. Jason, how much? No, I actually wouldn't do that at all. But I would do a lot for animals but that is where I would do the work. Jason, do you, I'm just thinking about Jason. He can't walk on a hotel carpet unless he's got slippers on. Socks and slippers.
哦，哇。我还以为你要说你得像喂鸟那样嘴对嘴喂它们呢。杰森，多少？不，我绝对不会那样做。为了动物我愿意做很多事，但这就是我能接受的底线。杰森，你……我突然想到杰森。他不穿拖鞋就走不了酒店地毯。袜子加拖鞋。
He's gotta walk. Can you imagine being in that? Yeah, I mean, you're there for two weeks. I would bring my slippers too. It's not crazy, but Jason, the thought of these animals in their bedroom. No, yeah. There's too many exposed bacteria ports on an animal to rub on your pillow or where other parts of your body might.
他必须走。你能想象身处那种环境中吗？对，我是说，你在那儿呆两周。我也会带上我的拖鞋。这并不疯狂，但是杰森，一想到这些动物在他们的卧室里……不，对。动物身上有太多暴露的细菌端口，会蹭到你的枕头上，或者蹭到你身体的其他部位。
It's just, it's not, it's a clean space. I just have like, no, I do not think that. Like when I think of an animal, I am just like, like I get in my car and I'll go on Facebook I do not think that. Like I get in my car and I'll go on Facebook, because I have a fake Facebook of a different person. I go in and I see in my community if there are any stray dogs that have been left, been dumped, and then I go and I pick them up and I put them in my car and then I take them to animal control and get them registered. Then I bring them back to my house and I microchip them myself
这简直……这不是一个干净的空间。我只是觉得……不，我才不这么想呢。每当我想到动物，我就会……比如我上车，然后我会刷Facebook……我才不这么想呢。比如我上车，然后我会刷Facebook，因为我有一个代表另一个人的假Facebook账号。我登录进去，看看我的社区里有没有被遗弃、被丢弃的流浪狗，然后我去把它们接上，放进我的车里，接着带它们去动物控制中心登记。然后我把它们带回我家，亲自给它们植入微芯片，
and I vaccinate them myself. And then groom them. I give them usually their first night will be in my house. And then I build kennels outside and I have a full staff. And recently I just got my rescue license. So now I'm actually a rescue. Wow, that's incredible. But now we've found over 250 dogs home.
亲自给它们打疫苗。然后给它们美容。通常它们的第一个晚上会在我家度过。然后我在外面建了犬舍，我有一支完整的团队。最近我刚拿到了救助许可证。所以我现在真的是一个救助站了。哇，这太不可思议了。但现在我们已经为250多只狗狗找到了家。
That is lovely. That's incredible. It breaks my heart that there is 250 dogs to be found. Actually, like in the rural parts of Georgia it's really, really bad and there's a lot of dog fighting rings, and I have a lot of that situation. I see that a lot. But Jake is amazing.
这太美好了。这太不可思议了。一想到有250只狗需要被找家，我就心碎。说实话，在佐治亚州的农村地区，情况真的很糟糕，有很多斗狗场，我经常遇到这种情况。我经常看到。但杰克太棒了。
Like he loves seeing the animals come in and out. Like he'll be like, Mill, like this one comes in for 24 hours and then gets adopted the next day, or sometimes the longest, you know, some of them have been with us is like around two years. So people are aware that they can go to your whatever
他很喜欢看动物们进进出出。比如他会说：“米尔，这只待24小时，第二天就被领养了，”或者有时候时间最长……你知道的，有些在我们这儿待了大约两年。所以大家都知道他们可以去你的……什么地方领养？
to adopt? Just, yeah, just the website. Like if you want to go on the website. What's the website? What's the website? It's joey'sfriends.com and you can view the available dogs we have, all of them. J-O-E-Y?
就……只要去网站。网址是什么？网址是什么？是joey'sfriends.com，你可以在上面查看我们现有的所有狗狗。J-O-E-Y？
Yeah, J-O-E-Y, joeysfriends.com. And they're all vaccinated, microchipped, fixed, house-trained, leash-trained, and crate-trained. So that's like a, yeah. Wow, I realize, if I don't find you a home, I cannot find the next one a home. So it's like the faster I find you an amazing home, the quicker I can get in my car and go and pull from another animal control
对，J-O-E-Y，joeysfriends.com。它们都打过疫苗、植入芯片、绝育、受过室内大小便训练、绳索训练和笼养训练。所以这是一个……对。哇，我意识到，如果我不能为你找个家，我就没办法给下一只狗找个家。所以这就变成：我为你找到一个完美家庭的速度越快，我能越快上车去另一个动物控制中心接狗，
and basically lower the euthanasia list. Can I go to the natural next question, which you're welcome to say I'm not answering that. I'm sure the desire to maybe have a child yourself one day is Burns Bright, question mark? Yeah. Yes? I mean, that is like, that is been-
从而基本上降低安乐死名单。我可以问下一个自然而然的问题吗？当然，你完全可以回答“我无可奉告”。我敢肯定，你内心深处渴望有一天自己也能拥有一个孩子，这个问题……问号？对。对吗？我是说，这一直是——
You're still very young. I'm still really young, but my mom actually had her first child at 21 and my dad was 19. And they, you know, it's been my thing since before I met Jake, like since I was a baby, like I told my mom, like baby dolls, like I wanted to be a mom just like the way my mom was to me and my nan, like my grandmother is like a huge,
你还很年轻。我还真的很年轻，但我妈妈生第一个孩子时其实才21岁，我爸爸19岁。而且他们……你知道的，在我遇到杰克之前这就是我的愿望了，从我还是个婴儿的时候起，我就跟我妈说，玩洋娃娃时，我就想当个妈妈，就像我妈对我和我南（nan，奶奶/外婆）那样，我的外婆对我来说是一个超级重要的人，
she was a huge part of my life. And so yeah, I mean Jake knows how important it is to me and like of course I want to focus on really establishing myself as an actor and as a producer but I also find it's so important to start a family for me personally, like it's a huge thing. Jake was like, we cannot do that until we get married. So that was his thing.
她在我的生活里扮演了极其重要的角色。所以，是的，杰克知道这对我有多重要，当然，我想专注于真正确立自己作为演员和制片人的地位，但我也觉得对我个人而言，组建一个家庭同样重要，这是一件大事。杰克曾说：“在我们结婚之前，我们不能要孩子。”那是他的原则。
And my thing was I really want a family. I really want a big family. Like I'm one of four, he's one of four. So it is definitely in our future. But for me, like I don't see having your own child, you know, as really any different in adopting. So I feel like anything's out. Because for me, like my home is full of love
而我的原则是我真的很想要个家庭。我真的很想要一个大家庭。我是四个孩子中的一个，他也是四个孩子中的一个。所以这绝对在我们的未来规划中。但对我说来，我不觉得拥有自己的孩子和收养有什么本质上的不同。所以我觉得任何形式都可以。因为对我的家来说，它充满了对任何人任何事的爱，
for anyone and anything. And so that is what kind of we stand by, Jake and I, is our energy in the house, is the door is always open and we want everyone to feel really comfortable. I'm headed there in two weeks to start this thing with David. More than welcome. The door is open, so.
这就是杰克和我所坚持的原则，我们家里的能量是：大门永远敞开，我们希望每个人都感到非常舒适。两周后我要去那儿和大卫开始拍那个项目了。热烈欢迎。大门是开着的，所以。
The door is unlocked. No, and so yeah, so that's kind of where we're at. We're very much like, we are always going to be, you know, wanting to start a family and it just doesn't really, it doesn't matter in what way or when, but it will happen for sure. That's so great. Well, Millie, one more time with the website. What's it called?
门是没锁的。不，所以，是的，这就是我们目前的状态。我们非常确定，我们总是会想要组建一个家庭，至于以什么方式、在什么时候并不重要，但这绝对会发生。太棒了。好吧，米莉，再告诉大家一次网址。叫什么来着？
joey'sfriends.com. joey'sfriends.com. That's amazing. Yeah, good's amazing. Yeah, good for you. Well, your absolute delight, Millie. Yeah, you are a delight. Thank you guys.
joey'sfriends.com。joey'sfriends.com。太棒了。对，太棒了。对，真为你高兴。天哪，你太讨人喜欢了，米莉。对，你太可爱了。谢谢你们。
Thank you so much. Again, please tell dad hello. I will, I'm gonna call him right now. He's gonna be very pleased to hear that you even remembered him, to be honest with you. Oh, this man, totally unforgettable. Well, have a great rest of your day. Go Bottle Feed.
非常感谢。再次替我向你爸爸问好。我会的，我马上就打电话给他。说实话，他要是知道你还记得他，一定会非常高兴的。哦，这人，绝对让人过目难忘。好吧，祝你剩下的时间过得愉快。去喂奶吧。
And thank you very, very much for doing this. Thank you guys so much. For me it was really, really cool to meet you. I've been a fan ever since. Thank you so much guys. It's been really nice to be able to talk to you guys. It's great to see you again even though you don't remember. No, it's okay.
非常、非常感谢你做这些。非常感谢你们。对我来说，能见到你们真的、真的很酷。我一直是你们的粉丝。非常感谢你们，伙计们。能和你们聊天真的太开心了。很高兴再次见到你们，尽管你们都不记得了。不，没关系。
It'll come back to us soon. Yeah, thank you guys. I hope to see you in person. I'll be there in two weeks. All right, see you there. Exactly, bye guys, thank you. Thank you, bye, bye. Bye.
我们很快就会想起来的。对，谢谢你们。希望能见到真人。我两周后就到。好的，到时候见。没错，拜拜啦，谢谢。谢谢，拜拜，拜拜。拜拜。
Now this is a good person. You know, this is, you know, I mean. That was really cool, like, for me. I don't know if you guys are as big of a fan as I am. By the way, she's done tons of stuff, but like, I'm a massive Stranger Things fan. The last season's coming up, I'm super excited. I've, you know, I love it.
这真是一个好人。你知道的，这真是，你知道的，我是说。这对我来说真的很酷。我不知道你们是否和我一样是她的超级粉丝。顺便说一句，她演过超级多的作品，但我绝对是一个《怪奇物语》的超级粉丝。最后一季马上就要播出了，我超级兴奋。我，你知道的，我太喜欢了。
Is there something, is there a spoiler that you were dying to ask her that she probably wouldn't have been able to answer about this final season? Well, no, you just want to know how it ends. Yeah, like why did it all happen? What was the thing in the, what's it called, the underworld?
有什么关于这一季你特别想问她，但她可能没法回答的剧透吗？哦，没有，你只是想知道结局是什么。对啊，比如这一切到底为什么会发生？那个在，叫什么来着，那个地下世界里的东西到底是什么？
What planet is it? What was it called? The upside down. Yeah, the upside down. Oh, you watch it too? I've seen it, yeah. It's a fantastic show. I love how cinematic it is.
那是什么星球？它叫什么来着？表里世界。对，表里世界。哦，你也看吗？我看过，对。这是一部极棒的剧。我太喜欢它的电影质感了。
All those kids are such great actors and she's amazing. Gaten Matarazzo too, he's great. He's one of the kids in the show. They're all great, by the way. They're all great. But Gaten Matarazzo was in Les Mis on Broadway as a kid. Yeah, what else Sean? Yeah, what did he do there?
那些孩子都是出色的演员，而她更是惊艳。还有加滕·马塔拉佐，他也很棒。他是剧中的孩子之一。顺便说一句，他们都很棒。他们全都很棒。但是加滕·马塔拉佐小时候在百老汇演过《悲惨世界》。对，还有呢，肖恩？对，他在那儿演了什么？
Oh, he's happy with this one. Go ahead, take your time. I don't have one. You actually don't have one. I thought you did. I thought you were leaning, you were, no? No, I got one, I got one. Oh, do you?
哦，他对这个很满意。说吧，慢慢来。我没有。你其实没有。我还以为你有呢。我还以为你在倾向于，你在，没有吗？不，我有一个，我有一个。哦，是吗？
It's gonna be bye bye birdie watch this. No, no, no. But's, but Will nailed it. One of the greatest things about Stranger Things is the upside, up, by, down, up, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, sss, she's got dual citizenship, right? Yeah, oh God, this one? And so she's, what would you call that? Bainational! Yes!
这下要“拜拜，小鸟”了，看着吧。不，不，不。但是威尔抓住了精髓。《怪奇物语》最棒的事情之一就是表里...表...拜...里...（嘶嘶声），她拥有双重国籍，对吧？对，天哪，这个？所以她是，你管这叫什么？双国籍的！对！
Bain! Bainational. Bain! Smart. Less. Smart. Less. See you next time. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
双！双国籍的。双！聪明。极了。聪明。极了。下次见。本集暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。